this episode of the gist is brought to
you by castlevania lords of Shadow to
serve valentine's day came and went and
while some of us spent it without
special someone others weren't so lucky
now what i could do is do it just
episode on five real-world places where
you can get into relationships with
actual people i'm not gonna do that but
what i am gonna do is tell you fine
video game characters that i'd like to
date yep let's get weird i'm a light
side white knight kind of gamer who's
really bad at being bad and
unfortunately that's exactly what got in
the way of my infamous budding
relationship in dragon age 2 this is the
only romance tree i remember looking up
a guide for a fact I now wish I hadn't
publicized on the internet but
unfortunately it's human nature to take
a bad boy or girl and try to change them
even you know in a video game Fenris fit
pretty neatly into that category he's an
elven warrior who used to be a slave and
is still pretty bitter about it and
hates being touched because of his
lyrium infused markings alright so he's
not a perfect pic just like that femoris
is pretty strong minded seriously tough
and really handy in a pinch if you can
get him on side or off side since dragon
age supports rival romances where heat
blossoms into affection unfortunately I
couldn't get either of those options
working for my protagonist so on to the
next one as for the other end of the
spectrum and proving that I don't have a
type mr. guybrush threepwood mighty
pirate might not be as undateable as you
think alright so he'd get me captured
all the time and leave in the middle of
the day to go insult swordfighting but i
challenge you to find a girl who doesn't
like a guy who can make her laugh guy
brushes basically what I think they like
to refer to as a fixer-upper he's a
little awkward and bumbling but if
birches on the side of charming rather
than embarrassing his witty adventurous
and most importantly is
totally loyal to his one true love
trying to keep him alive could be a
problem but i'm pretty sure we'd work
around it with some absurd
point-and-click puzzle-solving coming up
3rd on my list is probably the best all
the worst decision I could have made
because while bioshock's elizabeth is
lovely she's also kind of a ball of
danger putting aside the fact that we
would be constantly pursued and the
obvious daddy issues I kind of like the
idea of popping over to Paris at a
moment's notice through a tower not to
mention the fact that all the money she
throws at me during our afternoon
strolls could pretty much pay for all
our dates as a person elizabeth is
highly literate although potentially
prone to PTSD from being all locked up
in a tower and she's loads of fun at
musical events on piers I may need to
consider getting her some kind of GPS
tracker for all of the inevitable
running away but I think getting to
share her awesome wardrobe would be well
worth the effort and on top of that
chief super gorgeous you know her video
game character let's keep throwing that
caveat in there and pretend it makes
this video less weird planning in my
second to last place and a serious
contender for my favorite of all time is
the adorable and awkward Alastair from
Dragon Age I've had more than one
conversation with my female friends
about their dragon age go to Rome
ansibles and while layanna is pretty and
zevran has that roguish charm Alastair
seems to always be the favorite he's
compassionate as well as capable but not
even remotely in the know when it comes
to romance he tends to joke around
particularly to avoid being serious and
gets a wonderfully sweet and slightly
awkward scene where he'll bring you a
flower that he found as he starts to
like you he's your typical nice guy
proving once and for all that they sure
can indeed finish first if all of a
sudden our universe did go all her and
we could date fictional characters and
my obvious all-time go to would
definitely be liara from Mass Effect
racism be damned this is the 21st
century and a woman and an alien should
be able to date freely I actually stuck
with liara for my whole mass effect
playthrough even during the second
installment which she was hardly in that
was a lonely time for alia Shepard Lee
Aras damn me the best biotic in the game
perhaps
accepting Jack and she's an asari
scientist and researcher brains and
brawn aside she's also only a hundred
and six and is one of the sweetest
people who don't actually exist that
you'll ever meet sorry like to sort a
brain meld when they decide to go steady
which seems a little creepy from the
outset but if anybody's going to bring
you around to it then it'll be the
softly-spoken blue chick with that all
wrapped up let me know who tops your
dateable video game characters list
either in the comments down below or you
can do so on my twitter where i'm at
jess mcdonald till then i wish you all
the luck in your fictional dating
endeavors and i'll see you next week
you